well Richard Dawkins is very good at it
at framing science for his audience so
as an in running popular science book
books for a worldwide audience of people
who already have a strong interest in
science he's been a great translator
he's discovered the metaphors he's
discovered the stories the examples that
really unlock complexity for his popular
science audience get gets them to
understand better the complexity of
evolutionary science when he's now moved
into being an atheist leader he's very
good and The God Delusion at writing for
an audience of atheists people already
critical religion or people who are
questioning and what he does much like
Bill O'Reilly might do on The O'Reilly
Factor he provides talking points and
simplifies the arguments against
religion and connecting how science
might be used as a way to argue against
religion and people come away from that
book with their pre-existing opinions
intensified and also with a lot of
talking points to express their opinion
so in fact he's a social movement leader
now he's mobilized he's intensified a
movement that's critical of religion but
when you move then from his natural
audience out into kind of the swing
public people who appreciate science but
also all maybe moderate real religious
they attend church their friends and
family who are religious they probably
lacked the motivation in the interest to
actually buy his book but they do see
Time magazine covers that say science
versus God or they might catch a snippet
of one of his sound bites where he
compares religion to child abuse or
religion to fairies or hobgoblins and he
becomes then the very leading example
for Christian fundamentalist to say hey
everything we've told you about science
and religion being conflict here's
Richard Dawkins this leading theorists
about evolution he's saying exactly what
we've told you is always been always
been true is that getting evolution in
schools is really a way to undermine
religion Richard Dawkins actually says
if you learn about
evolution you're probably going to be
less religious or evolutionary science
is in direct conflict with religion and
and so in that case he can be a
polarizing figure he can actually be
used by the other side to undermine the
teaching evolution in schools at least
in the United States
the strongest objections are from what I
call the Richard Dawkins School of
Communication many of these people are
out there in the blogosphere they feel
very intensely about the connection
between science and religion they take
the viewpoint that science undermines
the validity of any religious belief in
fact even respect for religion and so
there the reaction is that to say that
science and religion are not in conflict
to to present evolutionary science in
any way other than just talking about
the facts of the science is not being
true to the science it's been it's
dishonest I've been called at neville
chamberlain atheist because i'm an
appeaser of an appeaser and an enabler
people who really believe in religion or
in God on the other hand other
scientists have the concern that this
might just translate into spin and
that's something that science
institutions should always be careful
about and that's why we always insist
when talking about climate change when
talking about evolutionary science when
you package that information in a way
that connects to a non traditional
public a non-science audience you always
have to remain true to the science and
in stem cell research that's a great
example in some cases where the
reframing of that issue around social
progress the ability to lead to cures
and therapies has gone beyond the state
of the science the uncertainty when
therapies can be available oftentimes
this has been promoted by politicians
such as John Edwards who in 2004 said if
John Kerry is elected president he was
campaigning for Kerry for vice president
Christopher Reeve would get up out of a
wheelchair and walk again of course this
goes well beyond any type of timeline of
therapy we might have available in the
foreseeable future and that's an example
where you can go beyond the science and
when you do that you risk public trust
so you always have to be careful but
certainly no one would ever suggest that
yo Wilson and writing the creation
growing the audience for science by
connecting it to religious values or the
National Academies and doing audience
research as a way to communicate
evolution no one ever suggests that yo
will sir the national academies are
spinning the science or being untruthful
about the science